welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special temporary primary host of the
show today i am joined by greg knuckles
he is currently the permanent guest
co-host for now
um if you like the show and you want to
support it there are many ways to do it
you can light rate like rate or
subscribe wherever you happen to get
your podcasts you could join our email
newsletter uh you could do that by going
to
strongerbyscience.com newsletter we'll
send you a bunch of interesting research
updates and our perspective on new
research as it comes out you can work
with one of our talented coaches we do
online one-on-one virtual coaching you
can go to stronger by science.com
coaching to check out our pricing and to
look at our roster or our team of
extremely talented coaches you could use
our discount code at bulksupplements.com
if you use the code sbs pod that will
get you a five percent discount off of
your entire order at
bulksupplements.com and finally you
could check out the mass research review
that's a monthly research review that we
publish along with dr mike zordos and dr
eric helms covering all the newest
research and exercise in nutrition or
you could check out our diet app called
macro factor which does offer a free
trial
greg road to the stage how is it going
yeah it's going well there's there's
nothing particularly exciting to report
uh on that front my my meat and fruit
diet is still going strong but since i
don't have much to say about road to the
stage i do have some corrections from
the last episode which uh
someone in the subreddit suggested this
as a uh as a section title for when we
have corrections uh so instead of
stronger by science corrections are now
wronger by science uh which i was last
episode on two fronts
one is uh
i i misstated that the phrenic nerve was
an offshoot of the vagus nerve it is not
uh it does interact with the vagus nerve
and can affect vagal tone uh but it's
not actually a branch of it just
misspoke there and then far more
importantly um something eric said i
noted that it sounded like a setup to a
bill hicks joke it was not it was a
setup to a mitch hedberg joke uh and i
greatly apologize for uh for that
confusion
that's bad because mitch hedberg he is a
legend uh well so is bill hicks i
actually haven't heard any bill hicks
stuff i'll have to look it up you should
you should check it out uh but yeah
mitch hedberg has a great joke about uh
being asked if he wants a receipt when
he purchases a donut uh and man it's one
of the best mitch hedberg had that way
of just like making these little
observations that were
useless not particularly uh insightful
in any way but he would just elaborate
on it it would be so funny
he he was one of the few people who
could put together a full special of
one-liners without it seeming like super
disconnected yeah yeah he was a really
really talented comedian um
all right road to athens uh i don't have
much to report uh but i've been all
about paddle boarding these days uh just
absolutely loving it getting out on the
lake as much as i possibly can
uh
and yeah it's great it's it's actually
made it kind of challenging to do any
other form of physical activity because
it's like i enjoy it so much
that i just want to be out on the lake
all the time but realistically it's
probably not going to keep my pecs where
they need to be you know like i have to
kind of talk myself into like hey you
should do some other types of exercise
but yeah it's been great really enjoying
it uh it's a nice way to get a little
bit of exercise and uh yeah just enjoy
nature and kind of float around out
there good deal uh feats of strength
what do we got this week yeah so so last
week i talked about some some feats of
strength on the women's side of the
recent ipf world championships um this
time talking about the men's side of
things and also some big performances at
usapl mega nationals which took place on
the same weekend
uh so yeah let's let's get right into it
so starting with the squat uh jonathan
garcia
set a new record in the 66 kilo or
145 pound weight class uh he squatted
271 kilos or
damn near 600 pounds 597
which uh
is wild to me like that just that people
in that weight class are now closing in
on 600
a decade ago that was not the case uh
russell ori in the 82 and a half
kilo weight class her 181 pound class
at usapl mega nationals squatted uh 320
and a half or
706 pounds that is a new record uh jamar
royster uh
macro factor athlete also all around
cool guy follow him on instagram at
pancake god
uh he squatted 332 and a half kilos or
733 pounds at just south of 200 pounds
in the 90 kilo weight class and i
believe that's the second biggest squad
in that weight class ever uh behind only
jesse norris and uh if you're coming in
second to jesse norris that is not a bad
place to be because my god that guy was
[ __ ] strong when he was really
humming and winning all the meets like
the numbers he was putting up were were
just stupid still are yeah yeah
the the numbers he was hitting in 2014
like he he was at least half a decade if
not more ahead of the rest of the sport
yeah uh let's see moving on to bench uh
the biggest bench of the day at ipf
worlds was also the most impressive in
my book
i'm gonna butcher this name i apologize
in advance but elias
buchalam
from algeria i believe benched 291 and a
half kilos or 642 pounds at super
heavyweight i think he's held that
record for a while but he he improved
upon it
and then on deadlift uh asean inohoro
pulled 362 and a half kilos or
799 pounds in the 83 kilo class that's
183 pounds at ipf worlds and i think
he's still a junior as well so already a
great lifter and uh fully expect to see
just some crazy numbers out of him in
the future not that pulling 800 at 183
isn't already pretty crazy
uh and then uh for for the totals uh
eddie berglund uh set a record a lot of
people think of him as
primarily a bench specialist which like
he kind of is he has a ridiculous bench
press but also just a great all-around
lifter he totaled 710 which is
1565 pounds in the 145 pound or 66 kilo
weight class
uh and uh russell orry he didn't quite
beat his best total ever but uh he did
set a new record in the usapl since the
weight classes uh changed a little bit
uh he totaled 838 kilos or
1847 pounds i think he's done 843 before
uh but like i said the the weight
classes uh changed from 83 to 82 and a
half so that's a new record for him and
then two final shout outs uh
one is bryce lewis
also a very cool guy i assume most
people who listen to this podcast know
who bryce lewis is uh if you don't check
him out bryce is awesome
he recently
made the drop from the 105 kilo class to
the 90 kilo class so that's 231 down to
198
and he used to compete
around that weight he used to compete
back in the old 93 kilo class uh i think
seven years ago and so he spent a pretty
good chunk of time at 105 and now back
down at sub 90 he's he's totaling uh
like
around 100 kilos more than he used to at
a similar body weight uh so at mega
nationals he totaled 845 uh and
previously he was totaling like 740 750
at a slightly heavier body weight
back in the 93 kilo class so props to
him this is only his second meet at 90
kilos and he is
uh continuing to make progress there
this was this was a meet pr over his
prior meet at 90
and david wilson he totaled a huge 900
kilos at 110 so that's close to 2000
pounds at 242
and he was
inches away from taking his weight class
i believe ashton ruska ended up winning
it but david was was inches away so he
pulled uh 375
for his second deadlift and uh he needed
to pull 400 and a half to win so so 375
i think was a two kilo meet pr
uh and then he needed to
he was he was 25 pound or 25 kilos
behind first going into his third
attempt deadlift so he just made the
jump all the way to 400 and a half which
would have uh won the meet by half a
kilo would have been like a 27 and a
half kilo meat pr which is just wild and
he was he was a hare's breath away from
locking it out uh so so props to him for
a huge total in general and for
a very gutsy attempt on that final pull
and i have i have no doubt he's gonna
pull uh 400 kilos plus in the near
future um
so yeah uh
david bryce also very cool check them
out and uh yeah last couple of weeks a
lot of strong people doing a lot of
strong stuff and bryce is coached by
eric helms right
unfortunately i was gonna say it's
always cool when you can see an athlete
who excels at that level in spite of you
know just really bad coaching yeah all i
mean that
you also have to hold bryce somewhat
accountable for that because he can
choose his coach
um it could be like a blackmail
situation now that i think about it you
never know
just kidding we love helms around here
um all right so for the next segment i
don't really have uh
a title for this segment it's just kind
of an update on something we've talked
about on the show before
i'm going to leave
some links in the show notes for various
resources for people who want to look
deeper into this
there's going to be a small group of
people for whom this segment is of
absolute top importance and really a
high level of interest and then for
other people it's just kind of
a passive interest in how the supplement
world works and a passive interest in
general gossip in the fitness industry
so there is some drama
unfolding in the world of phytoect
steroids um and we've talked about them
on the show these uh these are compounds
that plants make basically as defense
mechanisms and insects eat them
and inside the insects these phyto-ecti
steroids basically function as hormones
and one of the things that they do
is they cause the insects to uh
spontaneously molt and die
um which
i assume makes these paul saladinos
worst nightmare right like he's all
about the plant defense chemicals yeah
one one would assume um so anyway that's
what phytoactive steroids are
and the reason that they've become
popular lately in the fitness world
is um
it seems like they're on this like 25
year cycle where
you know phytoactive steroids get big
and then they kind of die down they get
big they die down
a while ago people were really into
beta ectesterone which was a phytoect
steroid people started selling it in
supplements
there wasn't a ton of human research on
it the the human research that was
available at the time was pretty
underwhelming not particularly special
and it just kind of fell out of favor
people lost interest in it uh within the
last several years terkesterone has
become the next
phyto-ecd steroid that has kind of
benefited from that kind of increase in
hype and interest that's largely been
driven by mechanistic data and you know
some rodent data where they've looked at
different phytoest steroids and how they
how they work in vitro or in rodent
models and they've said wow based on the
various phyto-ecti steroids available
it looks like this tercesterone seems to
be particularly anabolic not in a class
of its own but just kind of if you're
going to take one it looks like that
one's interesting uh but again when we
reviewed it on the show or talked about
it on the show you know basically there
wasn't a lot to discuss you know there
just isn't
relevant human data looking at
tercesterone supplementation and how it
impacts uh adaptations to resistance
training or
anything else uh i'm not familiar i'm
not aware of any
human trial involving tercesterone
correct yeah uh yeah it's it's not a
case where the human data is
underwhelming the human data simply
doesn't exist right um and so
tercesterone is not too terribly
different in terms of its theoretical
functions
its structure
it's not too terribly different from
beta xd sterone and so we talked a
little bit about the evidence related to
beta ecd sterone
it was hyped up a while ago it fizzled
out there was a a study within the last
few years about uh you know
i think it was beta actisterone in a
paper where there were some
really noteworthy uh observations
related to strength and hypertrophy uh
but it was it was an odd kind of
situation because they did uh testing of
the ingredient which is a really
impressive step to take for supplement
research
and they looked into it and within that
beta ecd steroid paper um you know the
the publication suggests that the uh the
supplement was pretty aggressively
underdosed uh they detected about six
percent of the
labeled content of beta-actisterone
uh and there was really no other active
ingredient uh implicated it was there
was like
a little dusting of leucine not enough
to matter uh from a physiological
perspective
and so looking at that paper and also
i'll note i'm pretty i'm like 98 sure we
talked about that on that paper like in
in quite a bit of depth on the podcast
before i think i think in one of our
first 10 or 20 episodes yeah uh
the the title if you want to check it
out is acne steroids as a
non-conventional anabolic agent uh colon
performance enhancement by ectisterone
supplements and humans by eisenmen and
colleagues if you want to check that out
yeah and eisenmann he's been doing a lot
of really fascinating supplement work
lately um he's done some stuff with
obviously beta actisterone he's done
stuff with uh cbd i i really like the
line of of research that that he's
working on um i think he's maybe based
out of germany is that correct i believe
so yeah but anyway so we kind of went
through that paper and we said okay so
beta ectisterone
historically the the literature hasn't
been that promising uh this paper it
looked quite promising uh and the
researchers were candid about it they're
like yeah
we got about six percent of what we
thought in this product based on our
testing
and so
what happened you know it could be
sampling error leading to false
positives it could be a placebo effect
it could be
issues with the assay for determination
of the uh supplement ingredient
for some reason maybe beta ecd steroid
worked in in this particular context
with a super low dose
there was really no way to tell exactly
what was going on um but you know it was
really hard to say yeah based on the
totality of the beta equity steroid
literature this is a safe bet you know
it was just kind of like it was
underwhelming then i'm not sure if one
paper is enough to really shift that
tide especially when it's a paper that
is you know apparently quite underdosed
that actual ingredient yeah and uh so i
found it in our in our backlog if if you
want to listen to our in-depth
discussion of that particular paper it
is episode 8 of the stronger by science
podcast and the discussion of it starts
about 57 minutes into the episode yeah
man episode 8 episode 8 wow yeah
um yeah so anyway
we basically approached the terkesterone
uh the last time we talked about
tercesterone we basically said well
um i i guess we'll talk about
beta-ectosterone because that's the
closest thing we've got in the
literature
and we will note that there seems to be
some odd stuff with regards to even just
the standardizing of doses of of beta
ecd steroids so we really don't know to
what extent those findings generalized
to the broader phytoactive steroid
literature and specifically how they
might relate to terkestrone products
so the new drama in this particular area
is actually really kind of coincidental
because
i'll link uh this really long
explanation of what went down but
somebody um did independent testing uh
someone with really extensive expertise
in in this type of work of uh you know
analytical chemistry and testing
ingredient uh for for meeting label
claims they did some independent testing
of a lot of trochestrone products on the
market
and they generally just did not have
much terkestrone at all
like for some of them it was like
1 600th of the dose that was labeled
yeah i mean literal dustings uh of
tercestrone if it's detected to a
meaningful degree
um but oddly enough some of them did
seem to have some beta ectisterone uh
not necessarily a ton in general
but what i thought was ironic about it
was we were back in the day we're like
well we don't have any tercestrone data
so let's look at the beta ectisterone
literature it seems like maybe we were a
little bit closer than we thought at the
time because
these products based on this analysis
seem to be more beta-ect steroid
products and and really have
just physiologically irrelevant uh
content of tercasterone
so there's obviously drama unfolding
because these
tercestrone products have been hyped up
big time people are selling them people
who have been purchasing them are
wondering what is going on here
there are a couple important caveats
related to this kind of
discussion as it unfolds first of all
i'm not a chemist and i'm not
particularly close to being a chemist so
i personally make no specific claims
about the methods involved for
ingredient verification i simply don't
have the expertise to jump in there and
say uh yeah i'm gonna lean on my
analytical chemistry background to
really correct some people
that's not me so i'm gonna sit on the
sidelines for this one and kind of watch
it unfold
the individuals and the companies that
sell these tercestrone products that
have been tested
i do believe they should have an
opportunity to state their case and
potentially provide contradictory
evidence and then people with expertise
related to this can weigh in and say
okay well there's this evidence saying
that the products don't have meaningful
amounts of terkestrone perhaps there's
contrary evidence to be assessed that
says no actually these meet label claims
and then people with actual expertise in
the you know really nitty gritty
biochemistry
at that point have to weigh in and say
which looks to be the more compelling
evidence here or or what what does what
just explains the discrepancy here so i
i definitely think that uh you know
obviously with any kind of thing like
this you got to at least let the
individuals and companies involved
state their case and say oh i know what
happened here here's what's going on
the third important caveat to keep in
mind is if a company is selling a bogus
finished product that is just way off
from label claims uh a lot of times it's
a natural knee-jerk reaction to say oh
they're fraudsters they're scammers they
knowingly have been doing this
at the expense of their consumers there
is potentially an alternative
explanation again if we assume that
these products really failed this badly
with regards to ingredient testing and
label claims um you know these these
companies are not sitting there
synthesizing and and you know extracting
their own raw materials in most cases in
the vast majority of cases those
materials are coming from bulk suppliers
and it is very possible that
well-intentioned companies who are
trying to put together
high-quality products are being deceived
from ingredient suppliers and they are
buying what they believe to be high
quality tercerone it's coming in and it
simply isn't
so it's very possible that some of these
companies and individuals might be as
surprised as the typical consumer yeah
and that's those caveats are just being
charitable giving the benefit of the
doubt well yeah i mean i i think in this
case that's pretty likely like there
there are some instances where
uh
the the circumstantial evidence for
malfeasance is relatively strong so like
for example when there was the the
scandal about amino spiking a few years
ago where people are buying
whey protein supplements that they
thought had like 30 grams of actual
protein per serving but it was like 18
grams of protein and then 12 grams of
like cheap individual amino acids like
you know like little lysine sprinkled in
or whatever non-protein proteogenic so
yeah yeah amino acids that were not
having the same impact on muscle
building correct yeah yeah so like in a
situation like that i mean like whey
protein is is a byproduct of dairy
manufacturing and when the the dairy
producers uh ship a a
big shipment of whey protein to whoever
wants to amino spike their protein
powder like it's it's not going to come
like that it's just going to come as
whey protein it would be
like weird and inefficient for the milk
suppliers to give like bad whey protein
to people so that was probably a
situation where people were
spiking their whey protein with aminos
after the fact to cut some costs but
yeah for for a situation like this i
mean um you know when you're dealing
with a with an herbal extract um
when people find that like oh there's
like virtually none of the active
ingredient in the product uh
you you don't want that to happen um you
know you wind up with a lot of egg on
your face
and you know it's it's not a situation
where like they're getting those those
herbal extracts from some other company
and then it's like ooh let's cut it 90
with some other thing
it it was probably just a case where
they got the herbal extracts from
another company and
what the other company sent them was
just bad like i i think that that's
probably more likely in this case
uh but yeah i mean we'll
hopefully know uh at some point down the
line yeah and you know it
yeah when you have to when you're kind
of weighing those potential
possibilities of like well
what was it you know a supplier who is
sending low-quality bulk material uh was
it the formulator the company that
actually puts together the finished
product that was you know uh making
mistakes or or worse yeah you know it is
one of those things you
you have to be uh
on the outset here you have to be
charitable with your assumptions you
have to be open to all possibilities
it's not a great look for a company you
know if these products if there's no
explanation that results in them saying
actually these have been meeting label
claims and there was some kind of error
going on
uh you know it's it's never a good look
if you've been selling products that
aren't meeting label claims because even
if there's no intentionality behind it
it's you know
as we all know uh
stronger by science we wrote an article
about dietary supplement regulation and
for better or for worse the burden of
you know
making sure that you're consuming high
quality products that are safe and
effective and meet label claims a lot of
that is shifted to the consumer a lot of
consumers like to to specifically seek
out supplement companies where they say
i have faith that there are really
robust uh quality control standards
involved here so that i don't have to do
all the homework right like i want to
buy supplements from a company that is
just rock solid and has really high
levels of quality control they're
testing their batches of raw materials
for potency or content as they come in
and things of that nature and using the
correct testing methods to check for
that um so yeah i mean there's there's a
lot of ins and outs here and like i'll
link the the initial post uh for the
person who did these independent uh
tests and as you'll see like
it's not straightforward i mean there's
a tremendous amount of detail and nuance
and information just in relaying the
results of the initial testing yeah so
this is complicated stuff well and i
mean another thing to note here is like
all of the tercastrone products seem to
be tragically underdosed which doesn't
doesn't feel to me
like
a handful of people trying to take
advantage of consumers it feels to me
like a global tercestrone market where
there are
zero good suppliers like
just like the the entire like global
supply of like tercestrone that that
might be then sold to supplement
manufacturers
it seems like all of it's bad yeah which
you know it is maybe in in part uh an
issue that the actual supplement sellers
should
be concerned about like hey if you can't
get your your hands on high quality
product maybe just don't sell it
but it doesn't seem like a situation
where
some people are doing things the right
way and some people are cutting corners
it just seems like no one can get their
hands on the real stuff in the first
place this tragically reminds me of uh
when i was in my mid-20s and found out
that i had never had real maple syrup
oh yeah that was i had never felt so
deceived in my life
growing up i would i would
eat pancakes or waffles i would have a
brown viscous liquid that was sweet yeah
and to my knowledge that was maple syrup
it turns out it literally never was it
was just like
liquid corn syrup with some artificial
flavoring and yeah then i had the real
stuff and i felt like i had been cheated
for
two and a half decades
uh but yeah so
in summary uh the beta actisterone the
terkestrone stuff it's interesting it's
fascinating it touches on a little bit
of how the supplement industry works and
kind of self-polices and self-regulates
um and yeah i would encourage people you
know
to uh keep some of those caveats in mind
like i said we're gonna have to wait and
see how the situation unfolds and get a
better understanding of what's really
going on here
you know i'm not i'm certainly not going
to vilify any individual or company
until we get more information and figure
out what what the deal is
um cool so
moving on
we just published an article it's
stronger by science on the show when we
publish a new article we often have a
little discussion about it so greg why
don't you tell us about the new article
yeah sure so the the title of this
article is the most commonly neglected
movements and muscles parentheses and
exercises to address weak links close
parentheses this is a guest article by
cameron gill who has written
uh two or three other really good guest
articles for stronger by science before
uh big fan of his content and um yeah so
so this one
uh i i found very interesting i think
this is my personal favorite of his
articles he's written for the site so
far um
and so you know it's basically like a
survey of
what muscles are trained quite well like
what muscles or muscle groups are
trained quite well by the big exercises
people commonly do in the gym so
pressing exercises
upper body pulling exercises
uh you know hip hinge style lower body
exercises squat style lower body
exercises and then what muscles are
neglected by by those movements uh which
you know might benefit from a little
love and so uh he identified uh three
kind of broad categories of muscles that
tend to be pretty neglected by those big
exercises that most people focus on
and that would be scapular protract
muscles that that participate in
scapular protraction so you know most
things were retracting our scapula so
scapular protractors primarily the
the pec minor and the serratus anterior
might be getting neglected the hip
flexor group as a whole might be getting
neglected so unless you're doing a bunch
of leg raises maybe
you know maybe you're doing leg raises
for the purpose of ab training but
you're also
primarily training your hip your hip
flexors if you're not doing any of that
your your hip flexors probably aren't
getting enough love and also your hip ad
abductor group
and so i i found this article really
interesting because one of the things
cameron did is is basically try to
quantify um
how
how much muscle mass are we neglecting
by not training these muscles and so you
know coming right out of the gate your
scapular protractors uh
on the whole take up
more total muscle volume than your lats
do and that's primarily from your
serratus anterior which i was surprised
to learn is a very large muscle group i
did not know your serratus interior was
that large but like in untrained folks
their serratus anterior is like 90
percent the total muscle volume of their
lats and you know where we we tend to
not train the serratus that hard
similar with the the hip flexors uh
overall the the total volume of the hip
flexors group is about 12 greater than
that of the gluteus maximus which i
think is the largest muscle in the body
um so you know if you're not training
your hip flexors that is a lot of muscle
mass that's that's being neglected um so
yeah it makes the case for why you
should probably want to train those
muscles how how much of your total
muscle mass you're neglecting if you
aren't and then uh you know a bunch of
exercises that you can use to target
those muscles um so yeah it's it's a
really good article you should check it
out
one question that's already come up uh
after sharing this
is uh someone basically asked like you
know if i'm if i care mostly about my
physique like why should i care about
this like what
what visual difference will it make if
i'm training my scapular protractors if
i'm training my hip flexors etc
uh and i think that in i think that for
the most part
you're dealing with with deep muscles
so
i think it's helpful to think of it the
same way you might think of like
brachialis training so
you know you don't really see your
brachialis if it gets bigger you're not
going to look at someone and be like
dude you have sick brachialis
development but since it lies deep to
the bicep when your brachialis gets
thicker it pushes your bicep further
from your humerus and so you know the
the top of your bicep peak is then
further from
the rest of your arm and so your your
whole arm just looks bigger and more
developed and i think that's the case
for for most of these muscles like um
you know if if your hip flexors get
bigger most of them are on the anterior
portion of your thigh they tend to
they they're they're either deep too or
in the same general area as your quads
so you know better developed hip flexors
will probably just you know someone who
doesn't know anatomy super well if you
have really developed hip flexors
they'll probably be like dude you have
huge quads uh or like your pec minor it
lies deep to your pecs kind of on the
upper and outer part
of your chest so you know it'll just
look like slightly better upper chest
development
if you if you develop your pec minor so
i think those are
are the sorts of visual differences you
can anticipate um but yeah there's
there's a
lot of muscle in your body that you
probably aren't training uh quite as
hard as the rest of your muscle so uh
you know might might make sense to uh to
to show those muscle groups a bit of
love
yeah and i mean i don't know if you
remember this but the the first time i
looked at this article when it was ready
for for some of the editing and revising
uh part of the process
uh my first response that i sent you was
like
man i wish this article existed
a very long time ago and was kind of i
wish i was forced to read it because you
know i i do suspect a lot of the um
neglected musculature surrounding the
hip part of me does
suspect that you know i mean my road to
athens segment right now has nothing to
do with running right because i have
this persistent hip issue that i'm
training around and trying to recover
from and trying to rehabilitate i really
think that giving a little more
attention to some of these neglected
movements and neglected muscles really
would have
facilitated my longevity as a lifter and
that's not to you know get into the hole
i don't even want to get into the whole
thing about training and injury because
people get all upset about it but yeah i
i would based on my personal experience
uh i really think i would be better off
from having focused on some of these
exercises earlier on yeah i mean we uh
so this article makes uh no claims about
injury and curry risk where
for written content especially we we try
to be very careful about
stating things that evidence supports
and not venturing too far into
speculative territory but yeah i mean
this is the podcast now this is the wild
west baby and i i
very much suspect the same thing dude my
i i have
at points in my life had uh like world
class strong hip extensors and just like
[ __ ] doo doo weak hip flexors and uh
yeah my my hips uh don't feel great my
back doesn't feel great you can never
cut you can never test the counter
factual i can't hop in a time machine
and see how my hips would feel if i had
been consistently training my hip
flexors but
um
i think that my hips would feel better
if i had been
like for me i i not long ago i was in a
physical therapist office and they did
testing they tested my strength of my
hips in various different uh you know
ranges of motion and planes of motion
and i said hey
why don't you have hip flexors yeah like
yeah i mean my extension uh was fine but
my hip flexors were crap my adduction
was fine but my abductors were crap
but yeah so i i'm not making any
specific claims about injury risk or
injury prevention but as someone who is
very annoyed with his hip i look at some
of these exercises and i'm like wow
that's what physical therapists tell me
i ought to be doing uh
doesn't seem like a coincidence to me
yeah so uh
shout out to jason for looking over this
article uh before we published it to
make sure
there weren't any unjustifiable claims
in it uh jason does not look over the
podcast before we publish it so uh
anything we just said in this segment
doesn't reflect poorly on him yeah
the the very tail end of that segment
was basically like historical fiction
right we took the basic elements of the
article and then just said well let's
put a little spin on it so yeah the
article has the good stuff and then the
podcast has just
random [ __ ] that we believe based on
wild speculation exactly um all right so
moving on i've got a little coach's
corner segment about a nutrition
question that i got recently
uh and there are gonna be elements here
where i kind of might
uh i'm not like intentionally straw
manning the the
the question or the argument that i'm
responding to but i have gotten the
question from so many different people
in so many different forms
i'm kind of responding to this kind of
synthesis of all these different people
with related questions right so the
individual that asked me this question
had a really firm grasp on the basics
but i'm responding to the uh
you know it's like when uh sometimes in
uh
like a like a historical fiction that
they will like combine four real people
into like a single character just to
kind of make it make the story flow a
little better yeah yeah i'm basically
doing that with this so
it's like a q a segment but i'm
answering like six different questions
from six different people but the
question is about macros while bulking
and specifically with carbohydrate over
feeding
now we have covered
protein over feeding previously on the
podcast and we've addressed the um
there's a bit of an argument going
related to protein overfeeding about
how likely or even possible it is for
one to gain fat with high protein over
feeding
and
in that segment we kind of went through
it and said well thermodynamics still
work uh we can go and calculate exactly
where the energy is going there are no
free calories in this situation yeah but
there are major impacts on
the thermic effect of feeding major
impacts on satiety and the more
controlled you get with those protein
overfeeding studies the less ambiguity
is you the the more tightly controlled
those studies are the more you can
identify exactly where the consumed
calories went
now with carbohydrate over feeding
there are
two kind of common claims that get
tossed around
one is
the fact that directly converting excess
carbohydrate to fat
so that that's called de novo
lipogenesis taking extra carbohydrate
converting it directly to fat for
storage
a common claim you hear is that that is
very inefficient
and that it rarely occurs or almost
never occurs and so people hear those
two things uh without any context or
nuance connected to them and they start
to get this idea like okay well if i'm
not going to
you know turn this into fat and store it
perhaps there's a little bit of a cheat
code when it comes to bulking which is
just i mean as long as you're going over
with carbs whatever you're not going to
store it as fat you'll burn it all off
no big deal so you know eat the carbs to
your heart's content
and what's really important is that the
term inefficient i think needs to be
operationally defined to provide a
better understanding of what that means
and even the term rarely occurs i think
it's very important and helpful to
contextualize that with a little bit of
nuance um
so
i i've seen the studies that a lot of
people use when they say hey de novo
lipogenesis is super rare so rare that
it's basically not even worth
considering in any context
and when you look at those studies you
will find that they are doing
very aggressive very high carb
overfeeding but they are not doing
radical fat restriction
and so usually what happens there
is
there it's certainly a high intake of
carbohydrate but there's still plenty of
fat being consumed there so
de novo lipogenesis rarely occurs in
that context because
that's not the path of least resistance
your body is not going to see all this
influx of carbohydrate and fat it is not
going to oxidize that fat and then take
the carbohydrate and convert it to fat
for sto for storage that simply doesn't
make sense energetically
and what you find is your body when
there's this huge influx of extra
calories and it's carbohydrate and fat
what your body likes to do is it'll
allocate some of that carbohydrate to
glycogen you know for sure
a lot of that fat is going to go
straight to storage and instead of
burning fat at rest which is kind of our
typical default state in a fasted
situation your body is going to say well
there's all this carbohydrate
storing it as fat is going to be a pain
in the ass let's just oxidize that
instead of the fat so like i said normal
fasting situation you're burning mostly
fat at rest
when you have this huge influx of
carbohydrate your body just says well
i'll burn the carbohydrate for energy
now
some of the carbohydrates going to go to
glycogen the fat i'm going to store that
and that's pretty much what happens and
and if the overfeeding is
large enough
and the excess energy intake is high
enough and it's super high carbohydrate
one of the things that you'll notice is
that
uh carbohydrate tends to have a higher
thermic effect of feeding than fat
and so when you're trying to figure out
with this huge influx of carbohydrate if
it's not getting converted to fat and
stored where is it going
you can start to piece together exactly
where it's going uh you can you can see
that it's being used
mostly to it's just being oxidized to
meet energy needs at that time
some of it's going to glycogen and uh
you know because there is a pretty
substantial therm it's not as high as
protein but carbohydrate does have a
noteworthy thermic effect there are some
extra calories that are just getting
burned due to the thermic effect of
feeding
and so
once there are some studies looking at
a very different scenario which is
basically what happens with
super high carb over feeding
with
very extreme fat restriction
and when you look at that research
things look a little bit different of
course there's still the high thermic
effect
or
moderate i would say thermic effect of
carbohydrate ingestion
there's no fat coming in within these
extreme experimental scenarios so
it's not going to be
you know kind of storing the fat
oxidizing the carbs what's going to
happen is with this really high carb
extremely extremely extremely low fat
over feeding
of course you know the body's going to
have that thermic effect of the meal the
body is going to oxidize carbohydrate to
meet immediate energy needs much of that
carbohydrate is going to go to saturate
glycogen stores and in some cases even
super compensate and kind of
really really pack in as much glycogen
as possible but after that
there will be some de novo lipogenesis
that occurs that absolutely has been
observed in the research and so the
question about you know is it possible
what are the situations where it might
be observed it really comes down to how
extreme is the overfeeding and how
extreme is the degree of fat restriction
so we have
everything we need in our body to do de
novo lipogenesis with carbohydrate it's
rarely the path of least resistance it's
rarely the path that makes sense because
there's usually fat coming into the diet
and we're just like whatever store the
fat burn the carbs
but i think because people often talk
about this concept without some of the
nuance and some of the details of the
studies some people have kind of gotten
the impression you know well just go
crazy with the carbs worst case scenario
you burn it all off uh but you certainly
won't store it as fat that's not
necessarily strictly the case but
practically speaking
uh you know you think of
i'm just trying to put this into real
world terms here let's say you're doing
a diet uh over feeding you're bulking
hard it's a thousand carbs a day
40 grams of fat a day 180 protein
that is
a pretty extreme macro breakdown i mean
that is only a seven percent fat diet
which i personally wouldn't recommend
but uh you know it's going to be hard to
get a thousand grams of carbs and 180
grams of protein without at least 40
grams of fat finding their way in there
you'd have to go really far out of your
way to make that work
so even in that context you're still
getting that 40 grams of fat coming in
that could be stored
and so if you're storing 40 grams of fat
a day
and you're doing that as your kind of
daily diet even with that alone without
any need for uh de novo lipogenesis
you're talking about over 32 pounds of
fat stored per year
so
what happens is we kind of look at these
isolated findings that are in different
situations with different degrees of
overfeeding different degrees of fat
restriction we start making conclusions
about whether or not de novo lipogenesis
is likely to occur whether or not it's
observed commonly and then that kind of
snowballs into this kind of series of
working conclusions about
what happens with high carb over feeding
so i just wanted to kind of
explain in a little more detail what the
situation is with high carb overfeeding
because it's definitely not a cheat code
there's no free calories happening here
with with high carb over feeding but
what you will find is like i said
there's a major shift in substrate
oxidation that's for sure
uh
in most diets even with some pretty ex
pretty low fat diets like i said the
example i gave was seven percent fat you
might not even need to do much de novo
lipogenesis at all there because there
is fat that's going to be stored there
so i wanted to clarify where some of
these carbs are going and if you need to
you absolutely can do de novo
lipogenesis and convert carbohydrate to
fat that is a relatively costly way to
store carbohydrate so you will use atp
in the process and so you will see that
the energy waste that occurs there is
elevated and so
what that means is when you look at
studies that compare head to head high
carb over feeding versus high fat over
feeding
if the calorie content of the two
overfeeding diets is equivalent you will
store more fat on the high fat over
feeding
and the reason is generally speaking
you're going to see a lower thermic
effect of feeding and metabolic pathways
for fat storage that are less costly in
that scenario so uh people will look at
these two
at interventions and say wow the the
high carb overfeeding led to less fat
gain than the high fat over feeding even
though calories controlled what's going
on with the missing carbs or the missing
calories from carbs it's just slightly
more costly or slightly less efficient
metabolic pathways that is leading to
some wastage just some some burning of
energy that is then because it's being
burnt not available for storage yeah
yeah so like to
to put things in perspective like
you know if you wanted to go the the
low-fat really high-carb route since it
is slightly more inefficient to convert
carbohydrate to fat than to store you
know maybe you could
get away with eating
an extra 100 calories per day or
something for a similar amount of total
fat storage because there is that that
bit of inefficiency that drag from
having to convert stuff but you know it
at least in theory it shouldn't make
like a night and day difference
and yeah and the thing that i find a
little bit ironic about this is
it is most pertinent to the most extreme
overfeeding scenarios so like if you're
really over feeding and you're in a huge
surplus by the time you get down to
energy deficits or energy maintenance
this effect pretty much vanishes uh low
carb versus low-fat diets there doesn't
seem to be a noteworthy difference in
terms of fat loss efficacy
and it's because a lot of this a lot of
the
energy wastage that's going on here is
related to costly storage uh processes
uh when when you look at low carb versus
low fat for fat loss it really doesn't
matter that much the the the difference
here starts to become more exaggerated
when you have very skewed macro profiles
and you have very large energy surpluses
and what's really funny about that is
the alleged upside here of high carb low
fat dieting
actually becomes a little bit more of a
curse than a gift because if you ever
talk to somebody who's
eating this way and they're going like
oh man i'm eating 5 000 calories a day
nothing that i've been trying is helping
me gain weight the last thing that they
want to be doing is saying oh great uh
energetically inefficient pathways so i
have to eat more food to get to the same
surplus yeah usually like this thing
that kind of seems like a bit of a hack
actually within many bulking scenarios
is a bit of a a slight disadvantage or
something that is to be overcome just
because you're like yeah i'm very very
full i wish i didn't have to eat those
extra you know 100 calories or whatever
it is
um but
the the place where this does become uh
slightly helpful
is because there's you know we can
allocate some of this to glycogen top
off those stores
if we are going to be storing some of
this carbohydrate in places other than
you know just straight straight to
glycogen stores it is going to be a kind
of energetically wasteful process
it does give you a little bit of a
buffer when you're trying to determine
the correct amount of calories to over
feed you know going a little bit over
with your fat because it can be so
easily diverted to to fat stores you get
a little bit of wiggle room in the
initial stages of kind of feeling out
like
it's a little bit less punitive if you
are starting a really high calorie bulk
you go a little bit over with your with
a high carb approach there's a little
more wiggle room in there so you can say
oh okay i'm a little bit too high i can
you know drop that down a little bit uh
but generally speaking
for for practical applications it just
really doesn't matter that much uh if
you are about to do a bulk um whether
it's a a very moderate bulk or a very
aggressive bulk uh when it comes to
macro breakdown
and just like your general approach
without question you need to make sure
that you're training in a way that's
going to effectively stimulate
hypertrophy that's that's the whole
point like that's the most important
thing you can do
beyond that you want to make sure you
have enough protein to to support
maximal muscle growth um uh
beyond that i would suggest that you
probably want to get at least three
grams per kilogram of carbohydrate on a
daily basis um in most cases that's
probably where i would start as kind of
the the beginning for a carbohydrate
target you can go well above that if you
wish um but yeah the idea that um that
you're going to kind of game the system
with doing these really uh
really skewed macro profiles during
bulking um i just don't think it really
pans out that way yeah so one one thing
i'll note just in the interest of of
full fairness
is there is
there is one particular study that
someone might cite to
to make the case that a really low fat
really high carb diet is a bit of a hack
and
what i'll note about this study
two things
one i can't find it anymore so it was
it was i believe a conference abstract
the lead author was mendez nedo from
2011. uh i first heard about this study
from the website subversity uh and we
can we can put a link to this in the
show notes the the link to the abstract
in the subversity site now directs to a
page that doesn't include the abstract
um see i i can't even find the the
original version of it anymore i don't
think the abstract was ever published as
like an actual peer-reviewed study um
and also just like the details of it are
uh are sketchy not sk i don't mean
sketchy in terms of like i think the
researchers did bad work but sketchy in
terms of like i don't think these
results would necessarily generalize
uh so
in in this particular study they
basically had people go on a thousand
calorie surplus per day with either
a high carb low fat diet or a
even higher carb even lower fat diet and
it was a 28 day crossover study so
ultimately they were only looking at
changes in body composition over a one
month period so
not not a long enough period of time for
the subjects of the study who who were
allegedly trained i think they had like
two years of training experience so not
enough time for people to actually like
build quite a bit of muscle
um
and so like the the study purported to
find that in the
high carb low fat but not super high
carb super low fat group so like in just
kind of the normal high carb group
over that 28 days people actually lost
muscle mass and gained a lot of fat mass
and then for the for the high carb or
the super high carb super low fat group
they gained less body fat during the 28
days but also gained a tremendous amount
of muscle mass and i don't even remember
what sort of analytical methods they
used in this study but i
strongly suspect that uh they were
mostly just picking up on shifts in
water weight and and glycogen storage
yeah um yeah i mean ultimately you know
we don't want to take too much away from
a single study ever
we certainly don't want to take too much
away
[Music]
when when talking about longitudinal
changes in body composition from a
28-day study
um
and also we don't want to take away too
much from a study that has
results that at least like on their face
conflict with reality like you know if
you go from 50 grams of fat per day to
80 grams of fat per day that is not
going to wipe out all of your
hypertrophy like that's not going to
make you go from gaining 1.4 kilos of
muscle to losing 0.1 kilo of muscle like
if you think that more power to you but
i think you're going to have a hard time
finding other evidence to make a strong
case for that but those those were the
results of this particular abstract
and you know
in the grand scheme of things not all
studies are created equal and
a conference abstract that i can't even
find anymore that never got published
probably shouldn't be weighted heavier
than
all of the rest of the research on this
topic um
so yeah you can you can check out the
subversity article about
about that abstract if you're interested
um and and we can put it there just in
the interest of uh making sure you can
see the counter evidence to
the the case we're making here um but i
i don't think you can build a
particularly strong case just on that
one study yeah and you know to be fair
uh if that's something that interests
you and you want to make that your kind
of default approach to um to bulking i
mean when when i'm trying to gain a
bunch of muscle yeah i usually uh
tend to really lean heavily on on
carbohydrate and protein but you know
the the only thing that you want to make
sure you avoid is going too extreme with
your fat restriction you want to make
sure that you're at least getting the
essential fatty acids that you need to
just be a healthy human being beyond
that if you want to experiment with it
um by all means you know go ahead but um
but yeah there's not really strong
evidence to suggest that
um that that this super high carb
bulking is some kind of a cheat code or
that there's this just inexplicable
impact on
inexplicable and reliably observed
impact on hypertrophy or fat accretion
generally speaking when calories are
ingested we can figure out where they go
uh and it's usually not uh
there's usually not free calories
involved yeah and i mean if you're a
researcher and you're listening to this
and
like to be clear
no one has replicated the the mendez
neto results but i don't think anyone
has tried to replicate those results so
you know if if this is interesting to
you and you're like hey i want to do an
over an over feeding study at some point
and you decide like uh yeah let's let's
do a high carb overfeeding study i would
be very interested in that i i would
like to read it i'd like to see
more
like direct longitudinal evidence on
this topic instead of
you know like the the tightly controlled
stuff
short term just looking at the specific
fates of of stuff you're taking in
that's all well and good but like who
knows how things shift over time like i
i suspect that if shifts occur
it would be
you know since de novo lipogenesis is
happening maybe just like an up
regulation of enzymes that help with
that process so if anything
if there are advantages to high carb
overfeeding i would expect them to
attenuate over time
rather than strengthen over time but you
know i could be wrong so if if you want
to do longitudinal research on this
topic i would love to read it
yeah i think it'd be really cool i mean
i was aware of that abstract uh
obviously couldn't find it but
um
when i first heard of it i thought it
was really intriguing and as someone who
by default would usually do high carb
bulking it's certainly
um
you know
i love some good confirmation bias as
much as the next guy but uh but yeah in
terms of making generalizable uh
statements about how one ought to
approach bulking there's really just no
evidence no strong evidence to indicate
that you uh necessarily need to favor
one particular macronutrient over the
other i think it really just comes to a
reasonably balanced profile of
macronutrients and just kind of honing
in on what the correct magnitude of
surplus is going to be plus like i said
most importantly just having a great
training program
all right you want to do a quick uh
research review yeah yeah let's do it so
uh
if you've been listening to this show
for a while you know that one of one of
our little one of our little buga bears
is uh
the idea of science by press release and
i regret to inform you there is
another example of it going around so i
was on twitter the other day and i saw
in my trending topics tab uh there there
was an article that that got put out by
uh
uh dang what was
what was this website i have the the
archive.is link pulled up
um ah dang it whatever so you can find
the article the title is from runner's
face to dodgy knees why running helps
keep women young but ages men uh
as i mentioned i have uh oh so here's
here's a fun fact for anyone listening i
don't think this is illegal maybe it is
uh i'm not i'm not a lawyer but
if you're interested in reading an
article on some news site that is
paywalled like you go to new york times
and it says ah you've you've read your
fry free articles for the month already
you gotta subscribe you don't have to uh
so there's the site called
archive.ph you can go there uh just copy
and paste the url from whatever article
you wanted to read there's a little box
that says uh i want to see if there are
archived versions of this page you put
the url in you click search if it's a
relatively popular article there are
generally like archived snapshots of it
you can click on those and and bypass
the paywall so anyway uh
that's what i'm doing to read this i
think the site was inews.co.uk
uh but anyway so i saw on my trending
topics tab
that the the specific phrase running
ages men had been
uh tweeted about
i think it was like 26 000 times in the
prior four hours or something so this
this is a topic
that uh
you know at least a few days ago was was
really uh taking twitter by storm you
may have come across this
um but the
the takeaway that a lot of people had
from this article
is that running is good for women but
bad for men like it it helps uh preserve
youth and longevity in women but it uh
it ages men on a biological level if you
run it's gonna be bad for you you're
gonna die early a lot of bad stuff uh
like that that was the takeaway and i
can understand why that would be from
the title of the article why running
keeps women young but ages men
um but as i mentioned this is this is a
situation of of science by press release
and just kind of a game of telephone so
uh when you when you pull up this
article
uh
unfortunately it doesn't link to
anything um like it's it's unclear what
is actually being reported on uh but but
i did some searching based on some of
the the experts cited in this article
and i found the press release that it
was based on so uh the press release
this will also be linked in the show
notes the title is endurance exercise
may affect bodies largest artery
differently in men and women
so the press release itself reads
the research funded by the british heart
foundation and cardiac risk in the young
and presented at the british
cardiovascular society conference in
manchester showed that older male
athletes had a stiffer aorta it found
that the vascular age of male athletes
aorta was almost 10 years older than
their chronological age whereas female
athletes showed no overall age
difference
however experts say the finding should
not deter people from exercising as
further research is needed to understand
the biological reasons underpinning
these differences they've also urged
that regular moderate intensity exercise
is beneficial for good health so like it
basically goes on from there it's
it's a pretty balanced press release it
says like hey we found this thing it was
presented at a conference uh you know
ultimately don't don't go out of your
way if you're a man to stop running
because
um
you know overall still seems like
running is good for you but that was the
press release and so then uh
people saw it they kind of took it and
ran with it uh so the the particular
article on inews.co.uk
briefly discussed that press release and
then most of the article was actually
pitched at women telling them like hey
actually it's fine to run
so it's kind of framed as a myth busting
article uh
i don't know what myths it's busting
necessarily but i also don't consume a
lot of uh endurance training content
directed at women so maybe these are uh
common beliefs people have so for
example they they try to dispel
the myth of runner's face apparently
people are concerned that if you run it
makes the skin on your face droopy
and uh and that's not good and uh this
article says like ah no like you don't
have to worry about that it's not gonna
make your face droopy so that's you know
that's kind of the the track that this
article took
but uh you know people seem to
pay most attention to the headlines and
so i'm not going to say the journalist's
name she probably didn't write the
headline it was probably an editor
but you know so there's there's
basically this game of telephone where
you have
uh a conference abstract not published
yet we can't actually read it to see
you know is there anything
methodologically worth talking about so
it's it's kind of a black box but
there's a press release about this black
box um
uh
conference abstract that's been
published and then that results in an
article that
overall the article itself isn't bad
but then that article has a headline
that says running ages men
and then that gets filtered on to social
media where you have literally tens of
thousands of people saying oh hey here's
evidence that running is bad for you if
you're a man
and so
it at each step in that process
thing things just degenerate and get
worse and worse and worse and i think
that
i think that this is a really
deleterious thing for science literacy
because i think i think before you get
to the point where you can put a
headline on an article that says running
ages men you should be you should be
forced to do a little bit of background
research to to you know quantify in what
way is it aging men and uh you know if
if the finding itself is good and
durable which you as the journalist
can't know because the study isn't
published yet
you you should at least have to like
temper it a little bit so you know even
if we take all of this at face value
like the the study found what it
purported to find uh a
lower aortic or i guess higher aortic
stiffness and male runners than people
of a similar age uh and you're saying
that that uh means running ages men so
you know if if that's the route you want
to go and that's like an argument you
want to make
and and just something you want to put
out into the world to the point that
you're actually going to
include a reference to that in the art
in the title of this article it might be
worth asking yourself like well okay
if running vascularly ages men what
sorts of things might you expect to
happen you know maybe increase
cardiovascular mortality in runners
maybe higher stroke risk and runners
because that's uh largely a vascular
condition as well
maybe elevated blood pressure like if
you're if you're getting increased
arterial stiffness blood pressure should
go up so then you can you can look at
the research on those topics uh and this
will be linked in the show notes but uh
2020 meta-analysis is running associated
with lower all-calls cardiovascular and
cancer mortality
and is the more the better a systematic
review and meta-analysis by pedesick and
colleagues and so just looking at
cardiovascular mortality no running is
associated with a 30 reduction in
cardiovascular mortality okay well let's
talk about a more specifically vascular
condition stroke
reduction in incident
in incident stroke risk with vigorous
physical activity colon evidence from
7.7 year follow-up of the national
runners health study by williams
this was from 2009
and
so the the result per kilometer per day
of running the age and smoking adjusted
risk for stroke decreased 12 percent in
men and 11 percent in men and women
combined
and that held even when adjusting for
baseline diabetes hypercholesterolemia
hypertension and bmi so once again more
evidence that if you're if you're
proposing that
running vascularly ages men maybe you
should anticipate an increase in stroke
risk you see the opposite
and then let's talk about blood pressure
specifically because again if you're
talking about vascular stiffness you
should see an increase in blood pressure
and
so another study running to lower
resting blood pressure colon a
systematic review and meta-analysis from
2020 by igarashi and nogami this will
also be linked in the show notes and
yeah in healthy people in people who are
at high risk of hypertension and in
people who already have hypertension uh
running seems to lower both uh systolic
and diastolic blood pressure so
you know in a situation like this before
before you can write an article that
says running ages men
especially if the specific thing the
press release is talking about is
changes in aortic stiffness you should
have to step back and say well okay if
this is a durable generalizable finding
what should we expect to see elevations
in blood pressure maybe increase stroke
risk maybe increased cardiovascular
mortality just bad things happening to
men that run and in fact we see
all of all of the opposite things
happening lower stroke risk lower
cardiovascular mortality rate uh lower
blood pressure so
you know ultimately like
i think it's i mean i think it's totally
fine to do the study i think it's
totally fine to put out a press release
to say hey we did this study
but i i just think that journalists and
journalistic outlets need to have more
restraint
before
writing about a study they can't even
read yet
um
and specifically editors putting a
headline on it that says
running ages men when you're talking
about vascular changes where like all of
the long-term evidence suggests that the
opposite occurs that if you know the
yeah i i just find this intensely
frustrating uh and you know like i said
this was all this was on twitter
trending topics there were like 26 000
tweets about this [ __ ] uh and
it could have been prevented with
with just a requirement for like a
little background research or even a
less inflammatory title because uh
here's a news flash for you guys no one
reads [ __ ] articles like i said the
article itself was generally fine like
it was it was a puff piece largely meant
to dispel fears of running in women
which
totally cool with like running running
is good for you i i support it
wholeheartedly but at some point in the
process
like it was like there had to be
a fear-mongering hook in the title to
drive page views
and
like that's that's bad like that's
that's how bad ideas get seated in
people's minds and i know that uh over
the next couple of months i'm gonna i'm
gonna run into people making the claim
that like oh man running is bad for
men's vascular health and it's not going
to be based on people reading the study
that all of this was based on because
that study isn't published yet it's
going to be based on people reading a
fear-mongery headline
that should never have been written and
uh yeah i
i find the whole thing uh very
frustrating and quite frankly
irresponsible
yeah and as are stronger by science
running ambassador i also find it to be
very frustrating um
anyway to play us out
i'm going to
continue the trend of giving music
recommendations now up to this point my
music recommendations have not been
particularly
friendly to training it's not really
been the type of music that most people
would listen to while working out you
don't do a lot of
alternative country or uh you know
blues specifically from northern
mississippi when you're training
but um
i i do enjoy some bands that play some
of the heavier stuff that might be more
uh conventionally compatible with
resistance training you know you go into
a lifting gym
and you kind of know what to expect in a
lot of cases in terms of what's going to
be playing on the speakers if they still
do that
but but i still enjoy music that has
a bit of complexity to it music that's
been put together
uh very thoughtfully in my opinion uh
music that
showcases uh a lot of excellent skill
and musicianship
and so a couple bands that i like that i
think you know potentially some
listeners might enjoy training to number
one is tool i've really been on a big
kick
listening to a lot of tool lately uh
they even have a song called the pot
which i haven't looked into the lyrics
too much
but i assume it's probably a cautionary
tale about gateway drugs if i had to
guess so very compatible with the show's
values and then mastodon
really really solid band again it's it's
kind of like heavier stuff i don't claim
to be like
uh
really deep into the culture of like
harder rock or or even into like metal
or you know progressive rock or
progressive metal that's that's not the
in group that would embrace me as one of
their own most likely and i don't claim
it
but these are some bands that uh yeah
like i said it's a little bit on the
heavier side in terms of rock
a little bit more conventionally uh
compatible with the type of things
people like to lift to
but still very very well done a lot of
excellent musicianship and just really
really enjoyable songs so tool and
mastodon if you're not familiar with
them check them out
damn that's just such a big change of
pace from all of your other
uh music recommendations do you ever
listen to either of them i could have
pegged you as a yeah i've listened to
plenty of both i could have pegged you
as a tool fan i would not have pegged
you as a mastodon fan i like them and
apparently i'm not the only one who's i
mean obviously there there's overlap
there but i was i was doing uh some
reading on the internet the other day
apparently they toured together uh like
way back in the day
uh i think they did a tour in europe
together uh which would have been a hell
of a show to see very nice so uh my
i think i think my second concert going
experience so my first was um
was van halen's uh um reunion tour so it
was interesting it was the first it was
the first tour where they had david lee
roth back in the band since like the
early 90s uh so it was the original
lineup but with wolfgang on bass instead
of michael anthony and
dude it rocked like yeah i i never
understood why
van halen was classified as heavy metal
but when you listen to them in an arena
live like you get it like it's it's it's
pretty heavy music uh also stand out of
that show you'll appreciate this as a
percussionist alex van halen had like a
six minute long drum solo which was face
melting it was absolutely incredible uh
the second show i ever went to
uh and i hope well whatever i'm i'm out
of the house now uh my parents don't
know this i i lied and told them i was
going to do something else
but it was called the unholy trinity
tour it was lamb of god mastodon and
behemoth oh wow and uh
oh brother that was
i think it was like 2006
so i was like 14 15
and uh man that was that was an
experience
um
but yeah it was it was awesome i would i
would love to go to another metal show
um like for so for for people who don't
listen to metal
i think uh
like i i don't like listening to it most
of the time like i have to be in a very
particular mood to listen to metal but
when when i do it's generally like when
the bat when the vibes are very bad and
i need catharsis and you just put on
your headphones or you know if no one
else is in the house you just crank the
music up really loud on your speakers
just just blast it for like yeah 20 30
minutes just really get the anger out
and then like you just you
like people who don't like metal i don't
think get this they think like this is
very loud and aggressive it makes people
loud and aggressive but no like when you
already feel that way it really helps
you chill out and i can tell you
uh walking out of the unholy trinity
tour i have never been in a more
zen-like state in my life that got that
got every
last ounce of like adolescent angst and
aggression out of my system at least for
like a solid day or two
wow you know i have a
a
very very very brief story that is the
complete opposite of that oh no so this
i don't know if that would be considered
metal um
so i went to
the wallapalooza the music festival one
year where uh
rage against the machine was headlining
nice um i think they were doing like a a
reunion kind of string of shows
and uh i i believe they finished their
set up their headliners so it was the
last the last sounds of the night
basically
i'm pretty sure they finished it off
with bulls on parade
and then the entire crowd just kind of
spilled into the streets of chicago and
i i don't know what kind of havoc ensued
from there but there is a large group of
highly energized
highly energized folks with just kind of
the seeds of a revolution planted in
their head uh yeah it was pretty pretty
wild but very much the opposite of that
but yeah i i think
i think i think rage is different it's
yeah it's very different because like
it's written to inspire like that that
revolutionary rebellious spirit and be
like all right now go do something yeah
yeah it's very very different um but
anyway yeah so uh some of the harder
stuff for folks who need something to
train to
all right so that does it for this
episode as always thank you for
listening and we will be back next week
with another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you could sign up for the free
newsletter at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you